on this flag day we celebrate our
patriotism it's also an opportunity to
honor the men and women who serve in the
US military the White House has
announced president Trump's first
recipient for the Medal of Honor
James mcluhan served as an Army medic in
Vietnam in just one 48-hour battle he
went into enemy fire nine times to
rescue wounded comrades
despite getting injured himself but some
people try to get recognition for events
or service that never happened Jeff
Laura met a veteran who made it his
life's work to bring those imposters to
justice
Jeff good morning Nora good morning to
you stolen valor is a term apply to
those who falsely claimed military
service either to gain recognition or in
some cases money it is offensive for
many Americans to think of but it's real
and because the government often doesn't
have the resources or time to
investigate private citizens pick up the
slack this is basically a memorial
tribute to all my friends and passed
away overseas in 2013 the show American
Idol featured a contestant with a
sympathetic story they were on a mission
in Ramadi Iraq and we came across an ID
and the IAT exploded met farmer served
in Iraq but was never injured in battle
and later admitted it was all lies in a
letter to the web site Guardian of Valor
when we out of American Idol that pretty
much started this whole thing this is
the web site guardian of Valor founder
Anthony Anderson
maybe the country's most prominent
stolen valor detective
he was defrauding a lot of people from
his South Carolina basement he works day
and night
separating military fact from fiction
we've had family members turn their own
family members in I mean it gets crazy
sometimes I've had sons turn their dad's
in I've had dad's turn their sons in
it's wild the website features a Hall of
Shame and links to video confrontations
a my son lucky me he really admires guys
in the army buddy this video of a man
claiming to be an Army Ranger being
challenged while shopping where to get a
basic training
or Jackson for Jackson you know only the
infantry only goes to Fort Benning right
has been viewed nearly six million times
on YouTube I wash your flag still low in
your shoulder to be up here got me on
that one but you get mad at these people
you do feel sorry for them originally in
the beginning I did I felt angry and I
felt sorry for some of them but now it's
just I really don't feel anything I just
know that I'm protecting you know what
our brothers and sisters have earned
overseas false claims of Battlefield
glory have been made as long as there's
been war you think I'm a no gay boy
else's mistake no but as you can see
from the online videos well
confrontations now can easily escalate
in intensity
break it up guys some of this work not
all of them some of it can come off as
the work of vigilantes right it can even
get dangerous it can if somebody's
falsely accused right and we have never
falsely accused anyone you know consider
yourself a vigilante no not at all that
we don't go chasing the seeker here in
the army or arm here we give them all a
chance to explain them fail
what's up with the dog how's my
standard-issue on canine it's very
important to veterans that the integrity
of the military reward system be
protected
Jill plans ler represents the 2.2
million veterans of the American Legion
and sees Anderson's work as a service to
the men and women who fought honorably
honor is a very important concept to us
so we don't really look kindly on those
who who lie cheat steal estimate retiree
flag my retirement certificate Anderson
who served 13 and a half years in the
army including a tour in Afghanistan
funds the site through donations he can
spend years on an investigation and says
he won't expose someone unless he's a
hundred percent I've got six or seven
guys that are constantly working these
emails yeah you do realize that this
patch first of all it's upside down
people never learn they never learned
the attraction of that glory is it's
just too great for some people you know
they rather impersonate instead of
actually good raise their hand and serve
their country
it means a big problem one of the issues
here is the services often don't talk to
each other so it can be very challenging
to figure out whether someone did what
they said there is also no comprehensive
list of medals awarded by the military
Anderson believes that should change
that's interesting that they don't have
record apprehensive list is very tough
to figure out yes I understand his
passion and he's 100% right it is I just
can't understand how people think they
can get away with it even though they do
we all ask that question right and I do
it and I they was universe it in any way
alright thank you Jeff